okay here is an update to the Bret Keene
story so to catch you up if you're not
aware of what's been going on we have
been receiving a series of voicemails at
our voicemail number which is two one
nine two david p from someone who just
spouts religious dogma and
interpretations of religious texts and
little bits of religious texts and after
we played a couple of this guy's
voicemails several people wrote in
saying david that sounds like brett keen
yep now i had no idea who brett keen was
but pat explained to me that brett keen
is a former atheist turned yes chin he
used to be one of the biggest atheist
on youtube okay and then eventually he
became a christian he got kicked off of
youtube multiple time okay and then he
was like the chief antagonist on the
drunken peasants show right which is the
now-defunct drunk hasn't I went to the
Brett Keene YouTube channel and the
voice did sound similar but the
confusion was that Brett Keene I guess
is in his early 40s 41 I think and the
caller said that he's 54 years old and
even though Brett cane to me looks like
he's in his mid-50s Pat assured me that
he's not so anyway we speculated the
other day is the religious caller Brett
Keene the real Brett Keene has now
called into the show he recorded himself
calling in and leaving the voicemail and
that recording is way better than the
voicemail he left us which is all
garbled and staticky and I think it is
abundantly clear that it was not
actually Brett cane who called in before
this is Brett Keene calling in to the
David Pakman show
hello my name is Brett Keene from god TV
radio calm make sure that you connect
with me on Facebook and Twitter
quaggan when you get a chance check out
my articles and also some of my new
t-shirt designs you're gonna love them
plug it remember my youtube channel is
Brett King god TV radio very easy to
remember yeah and by the way I noticed
that you thought that I was like 57
years old or 60 don't let the premature
gray hair fool you
my wife calls me the gray fox for a
reason have a good day mr. pac-man yes
oh by the way my phone number is six
three six call me back babycakes okay
yeah we are cut out the rest of his
voicemail the rest of his phone number I
don't know why he docked himself I know
yeah we I was not I was not gonna air
that that part of it I wonder why he
wants to talk to me but anyway are we
ready to say that the religious caller
is definitely not Brett King oh yeah I
was ready to say that last week oh you
were okay pretty much well now I've come
around and I'm ready to say it as well
but I think he likes you
it seems like he does kind of like the
like the whole thing yeah hey give you a
smooch anyway thanks for calling in the
real Brett Kane we don't know who the
other dude is and we may never on the
bonus show today the Senate has rejected
a measure to ban abortion after 20 weeks
of pregnancy there is a California
lawmaker who is taking some flak over a
plastic straw bill and I actually have
some strong feelings about plastic
versus paper straws I had a horrible
incident horrible horrible incident
involving paper straws over the weekend
and I will talk about that it's not what
you think it's not like perverted Pat's
already thinking Oh Oh God
I will talk about that on the bonus show
and also we will talk about a Joe
Kennedy the third who is going to be
doing the rebuttal to trump State of the
Union address tonight tomorrow we will
talk about Donald Trump's first official
State of the Union address
get access to the bonus show one of two
ways become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show or become a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership